let me go position Sanchez over Anana
that's guaranteed Reese J yeah 100% 100%
Sanchez over Anana that's guaranteed
mate
Anana listen listen what Anana starting
to come good in the last couple of games
how good is he coming or is that a
reflection of how poor he was the jury's
massively out on him for the for this
moment in time Sanchez over an Anor for
me yeah mate come on man look
look at the saves that Sanchez is
pulling off what I'm saying is Sanchez
of course is playing a poor side at the
moment yeah Sanchez is but a he's the
average keeper yeah he is yeah well you
going to say's that saying he is there
you go Sanchez is average agreed but
Anana Anana is a little bit worse than
average for me let me say